public sénat et éco des ds vous présente
pourvu que ça dure
[Musique]
m
bonjour bienvenue dans ce nouveau numéro
de points que ça dure l'émission tirant
les co-responsables sur public sénat
aujourd'hui émission spéciale consacrée
aux femmes dans le monde de l'entreprise
inégalités salariales burn-out maternité
réunions tardives conciliation entre vie
privée et vie pro et oui pas facile de
trouver sa place au boulot quand on est
une femme alors pour y remédier faut-il
instaurer des quotas de femmes aux
postes à responsabilité
réponse dans quelques instants on
s'intéressera également aux femmes
entrepreneuses elles sont de plus en
plus nombreux à se lancer mais pour elle
vous le verrez les obstacles ne manquent
pas enfin c'est l'une des rares femmes à
la tête d'une société cotée en bourse
julie walbaum la patronne de maisons du
monde nous racontera sa vie de femme
chef d'entreprise mais d'abord tout ce
qu'il faut savoir sur la place des
femmes au travail ces parties
travaillent les femmes et les hommes sur
un pied d'égalité vraiment
depuis dix ans il y a eu des progrès
grâce à l'instauration de quotas on
compte 46 % de femmes dans les conseils
d'administration
mais dans les comités exécutifs elles ne
sont que 22% tandis que 35% des sociétés
sont dirigées par des femmes à côté
salaire à temps de travail égal elles
gagnent presque 17% de moins logique
elles accèdent moins aux emplois les
mieux rémunérés les temps partiels sont
occupés à 80% par des femmes tout comme
70% des cdd et des contrats d'intérim
elle représente 90 % des aides soignants
et des auxiliaires de vie est moins de
30% des ingénieurs de l'informatique
avec la crise leur situation s'est
dégradée pendant le premier confinement
les maires ont peu fois plus souvent
renoncer à travailler pour garder les
enfants les femmes en télétravail sont
34% à s'estimer au bord du burn out soit
21 points de plus que les hommes
la france est aujourd'hui championne du
monde de la mixité dans les conseils
d'administration mais il faut aller plus
loin pendant qu'elle a tari bonjour 7
coordinatrice du pôle égalité
hommes-femmes de terra nova ya ce
chiffre qui montre qu'on est champion du
monde 45 % 45 % des sièges des conseils
ministration sont désormais occupés par
des femmes on revient de loin on était
12 % en 2010 est-ce que ça prouve que la
contrainte en l'espèce cette loi copé
zimmermann voter pour le coup en 2010
qui imposait cette montée en puissance
des femmes au sein des conseils et bas à
la loi ça marche en effet ça marche on
observe bien que c'est là où on a mis
des quotas que les choses ont bougé où
l'avez rappelé on est passé de 12 15 %
de femmes dans les conseils
d'administration à 45% de leader on sait
les meilleurs on est meilleur on est
parti on est partis de bas mais
aujourd'hui effectivement on est les
meilleurs bon sauf que le conseil
administration c'est le haut de la
pyramide de l'entreprise ce qu'il faut
après c'est de descendre d'un cran j'ai
envie de dire et féminisé d'autres
instances dirigeantes en au delà du
conseil c'est pourquoi cette loi la
loire x 1 était voté fin 2021 elle
impose je le rappelle pour les sociétés
de plus de 1000 salariés
30% de femmes parmi les cadres
dirigeants d'ici 2027 et 40% d'ici 2030
est ce que cette loi c'est une vraie
question est ce que c'est l'assurance
que plus de femmes auront des postes à
responsabilité dans le futur mais je
pense qu'on a de bonnes raisons d'être
optimiste ça a marché dans les conseils
d'administration mais là où la loire x1
est intéressante c'est parce que on
pensait en féminisant les conseils
d'administration qu'automatiquement on a
les féminiser l'échelon du dessus
que sally ruisseler c'est le terme qu on
utilise souvent
ça a été le cas au niveau des comités
exécutifs ou décodeur donc ses
directeurs directrice marketing
communication stratégie etc on n'a pas
eu ce décollage donc effectivement
imposé encore une fois ce qu'on appelle
des quotas donc 30 ou 40% de femmes dans
ses instances et a de bonnes raisons
pour que ça pour que ça fasse bouger les
choses donc pour vous à vous écouter
cette loi c'est une avancée qui est
majeure même si j'allais dire elle ne
s'applique pas aux pme et là on se dit
effectivement la mixité de la mixité
dans les pme il ya un sujet oui c'est
vrai alors déjà évidemment les pme les
tpe ne sont pas soumises à cette
obligation parce que de par leur taille
elles m'ont ni parfois pas de conseil
d'administration pas de comité exécutif
donc évidemment on a on a moins la
possibilité de surveiller ou d'imposer
ou de contraindre ça risquerait plus de
difficultés à s'organiser mais on
pourrait imaginer par exemple
d'encourager plutôt les pme qui qui
aurait autant de femmes que d'hommes
dans leurs dirigeants par différentes
mesures ça pourrait être
en accès privilégié à certains marchés
publics par exemple ou alors conditionné
voilà c'est ce qu'on entend aussi
souvent en ce moment
l'écoconditionnalité on pourrait penser
à de l'écho et gars conditionnalité
pourquoi pas pour pour être dans une
logique plutôt de valorisation de ces
entreprises plus petites qui feraient le
boulot et pour les boîtes qui font pas
le boulot qui ne respectent pas cette
loi ricin ce que est ce qu'il ya des
amendes et ce qu'elles sont vraiment
dissuasive oui c'est 1% de la masse
salariale a quand même
c'est dissuasif après quand on quand on
veut recruter en interne
promouvoir des femmes est ce qu'on les
trouve vraiment je pose la question
parce que le patronat le medef n'est
elle pas trop non sens large
parfois on entend souvent que certains
profils sont rares sur le marché profils
féminins et les secteurs où la question
se posera peut-être le btp mais sinon
voilà est-ce que c'est un argument c'est
une réalité où est ce que tu sais pas un
peu spécieux comme un argument ça quand
on cherche on trouve non c'est vrai
qu'on a de la difficulté à trouver des
femmes dansent à certains secteurs
d'activité mais aussi à certains postes
parce que on le sait femmes et hommes
n'exerce pas au même niveau hiérarchique
ni aux mêmes métiers ni dans les mêmes
secteurs d'activité donc effectivement
on a de la difficulté quand on regarde
un peu la composition d
de ces comités de direction on sait
qu'on a beaucoup plus d'hommes qui vont
être dans des fonctions de
communication des ressources humaines
aux femmes le marketing aux femmes c'est
schématique c'est vraiment pour le coup
c'est pas caricatural ya une part de
vérité on en est encore là aujourd'hui
mais les postes pour les hommes et puis
des postes pour les femmes alors je
dirais pas que ce sont des postes pour
les hommes ou pour les femmes mais pour
le comprendre il faut regarder ce qui se
passe un petit peu en amont du marché du
travail aujourd'hui il ya un peu de
métier qui sont mixtes et on a encore
des filières d'études dans lesquels on a
beaucoup de femmes dans les filières du
soin de l'éducation de la beauté et du
bien-être on va avoir beaucoup de femmes
alors que dans les filières du btp de
l'industrie chez les ingénieurs on va
encore avoir beaucoup d'hommes on est
quand même souvent dans un prisme qui
consiste à vouloir attirer les femmes
vers des métiers masculins mais en fait
assez peu l' inverse on se dit peu
essayons d'attirer des hommes dans les
métiers par exemple du soin qui sont des
métiers d'avenir les métiers de la santé
sont des métiers d'avenir est en réalité
on retrouve aussi cette répartition très
genre et donc différenciée selon les
sexes mais il faudrait inciter les deux
à ouvrir leur champ des possibles les
hommes comme et sur la tête encore une
fois ça vient d'où le fait qu'il psy peu
de femmes qui soient embauchés dans ces
métiers là on retrouve la maison on
préfère des métiers prometteur d'avenir
pour lesquels il ya même de la pénurie
oui c'est vrai c'est vrai et ça on
l'expliqué très bien c'est que de
manière assez précoce dans leur choix
d'orientation
on va commencer ça commence à l'école
évidemment au moment où on est on à 13
14 ans on est un ado on s'oriente il ya
quelque chose de très fort qui fait qu'
on a besoin de s'identifier à un groupe
de pairs on a
besoin de prouver qu'on est une vraie
fille un vrai garçon et ça passe aussi
par adopter ce qu'on suppose être les
compétences les préférences supposée des
filles et des garçons et ça c'est très
fort il faut pas le sous-estimer en tout
cas cette loi rixin va dans le bon sens
c'est une avancée voilà merci beaucoup à
kenza tarifs une coordinatrice du pôle
égalité homme-femme de terra nova merci
de plus en plus de femmes se lancent
dans la création d'entreprise un
parcours parfois semée d'embûches daniel
en 2019 à la veille de la crise
sanitaire
la france enregistre un nouveau record
de créations d'entreprises 810 miller
nanan mais en y regardant de plus près
seuls 40 % d'entre elles sont initiées
par des femmes une proportion qui a
doublé en 25 ans mais qui n'atteint
toujours pas la parité en 2021
pourquoi les femmes sont elles en
retrait dans le monde de
l'entrepreneuriat quels sont les freins
pour mieux comprendre nous avons
rendez-vous en vendée avec sandrine
mourier sommelière de 29 ans sur le
point de réaliser un rêve ouvrir sa cave
à vin ça fait dix ans que réellement je
souhaite
j'ai peur j'ai peur de l'aventuré c'est
encore le grand flou
[Musique]
très bien chanté merci à l'internal de
choses à se raconter oui je vends fait
ici ses marques et
sandrine a rendez vous avec armelle une
chef d'entreprise à la tête d'un centre
de formation réputé dans le secteur du
tourisme la tentation de septembre à
décembre avec les stagiaires qui se
forment au métier de chaque projet
ces deux femmes ne se sont jamais vus
elles ne sont pas dans le même domaine
et pourtant elles vont échanger le temps
d'une journée sur le parcours
d'entrepreneuses c'est ce que td en tout
cas par rapport à mon parcours et je
peux te donner peut-être des conseils
des pistes pour aborder en fait tout
cela sereinement comme armel 8000 femmes
chefs d'entreprises participent à ces
rencontres partout en france cela
s'appelle vis ma vie d'entrepreneuses et
c'est patricia l'excellent qui en est à
l'origine
apparemment les femmes semaine un peu
plus de 5 un homme au moment de passer à
de l'idée à la concrétisation du projet
de création est ce que je suis vraiment
capable est ce que je pourrais assumer
une fois que j'ai fait cette entreprise
donc tous ces petits frein là qui sont
psychologiques l'idée c'est d'élever au
moment et grâce à la rencontre avec des
femmes qui sont passés par le même
parcours crainte de ne pas être à la
hauteur de ne pas être légitime mais
aussi la peur de ne pas réussir à
jongler entre la vie de famille les
tâches domestiques et le pilotage d'une
entreprise une société patriarcale qui
peineraient à évoluer sur les questions
d'égalité femmes-hommes
moi aujourd'hui c'est vrai que j'ai
quand même pas mal réticence à j'ai une
famille j'ai aussi un conjoint en
quittant métier on pour ouvrir un vote à
séverac cc c'est le grand bond 1 c'est
sortir de sa zone de confort j'ai eu des
nuits blanches j'ai eu des fois où je me
suis dit mais dans quoi je me lance est
ce que vraiment il faut que j'aille au
bout ou pas et moi j'élève mon fils tout
seul et c'était un vrai challenge et
mais c'est normal d'avoir des doutes
on parle beaucoup la charge mentale chez
la femme et les nomme on a plusieurs
vies en une même journée malgré ce qu'on
dit que l'homme participe plus aux
tâches etc est ce que c est ce que c'est
réellement vrai dans la dans la réalité
je ne suis pas sûr et peut-être que ça
empêche certaines femmes justement de se
lancer parce que la peur de ne pas
pouvoir assumer justement tout c'est
toute cette masse de travail
et la crise sanitaire n'aurait pas
arrangé la situation
selon nicolas bouzou économiste les
femmes auraient sacrifié davantage leur
projet professionnel que les hommes on a
des études qui montrent que pendant le
confinement les femmes se sont beaucoup
plus s'occuper des enfants que les
hommes bien souvent les hommes étaient
en télétravail et les femmes étaient
arrêtés en arrêt maladie par exemple
pour s'occuper des pour s'occuper des
enfants et donc ma crainte c'est que la
crise et consolidé en quelque sorte d
équilibre et je me demande même si au
fond avec cette crise qui aura duré deux
ans on a aussi perdu deux ans en matière
d'égalité hommes femmes des femmes moins
nombreuses à la tête d'entreprises et
surtout qui ose prendre moins de risques
levée de fonds plus faible demande de
prêt à la banque moins élevé du coup à
l'arrivée elles ont un chiffre
d'affaires plus faible que les hommes et
puis aussi côté statut les ambitions
sont revues à la baisse
40 % des entreprises sont créées par des
femmes et est revenu que tous ces femmes
est liée à cette création d'entreprise
en fait elles sont plus celles que les
revenus les qui sont perçues par les
hommes parce que ce sont souvent de
petites structures voire carrément des
micro-entreprises pourtant selon une
étude menée par women equity partners
sur quarante mille entreprises de taille
moyenne celle dirigée par les femmes
seraient plus rentable de 32%
c'est l'une des rares femmes à diriger
une grande société cotée en bourse pour
genève album bonjour david ça va très
bien merci vous installez vous traverse
directrice générale de maisons du monde
alors seules trois femmes aujourd'hui
son patron d'une boîte du cac 40 on va
les donner à ces chez angie chez orange
depuis peu et chez olias est prévu pour
les prochains mois trois sur 40 qu'est
ce qu'on se dit on se dit quoi que le
compte n'y est pas en matière de parité
c'est mathématique ou qu' il ya trois
mois et ben n'y avait qu'une seule femme
patrons du cac 40 et donc voilà que les
choses sont peut-être en train de
s'accélérer comment ce qu'on voit la
chose perdre ou à moitié vide on
multiplie alors moi je suis d'un naturel
optimiste donc j'ai plutôt tendance à
avoir ça comme une voie de progrès et si
je prends le sbf 120 lors de ma
nomination 2018 ont été à peine 8
maintenant on est 13 ou 14 donc ça aussi
je pense que ça répondait bien sûr il
reste du chemin à faire pour une femme
accéder au sommet de la pyramide au
sommet de l'entreprise ça reste un
chemin pavé d'embûches qui a encore
inscrit un penalty à fond de verre alors
les statistiques et l'indic donc ce
plafond des recettes une réalité d'après
les chiffres moi je n'ai jamais vécu
comme tel je n'ai jamais ressenti ce
plafond de verre et je pense que c'est
lié à à deux raisons la première c'est
que je me suis jamais senti moins
capable je n'ai jamais eu l'impression
que j'avais moins droit à qu'un homme et
je pense que c'est le resta de plein de
choses c'est un tempérament une
éducation en environnement et je pense
que du coup il faut que l'on commence
très tôt dans l'éducation dans la
sensibilisation à ces biais cognitif
culturel pour que justement les petites
filles se disent qu'ils sont au moins
autant capable qu'elles ont au moins
droit à donc je pense que ça c'est
technologique c'est à dire que voilà
parce que l'art et essai que les femmes
ont toujours du mal à accéder
aujourd'hui à des postes de direction et
à la loire x5 été votée justement pour
qu'ils cèdent pas 30 40 % d'ici d'ici
quelques années voilà il ya je crois
qu'il ya beaucoup de de croyances et de
limites personnelles que les femmes
s'imposent des freins des francas sur
lesquels collectivement on doit
travailler le premier frein c'est le
manque de confiance en soi on parle
souvent du syndrome de l'imposteur
de ce complexe en effet des femmes qui
se disent que l n'y arriveront pas
qu'elle ne mérite pas qu'ils ne pourront
pas faire face donc ça c'est très
important et puis aussi une deuxième
croyances parce que je pense que c'en
est véritablement une des femmes qui est
de dire mais si je veux réussir je vais
sacrifier tout le reste et ça ce n'est
pas possible ma vie ne se définit pas
que par mon travail on doit aussi
travers cette croyance donc c'est un
concept qu'on peut donner aux femmes qui
nous regardent qui souhaitent accéder à
des postes avec plus de responsabilités
ces mots-là de croire en elle de croire
que c'est possible et de si je crois ma
propre expérience disons que si j'avais
eu cette conviction que pour accéder à d
autres responsabilités je devais
sacrifier ou grande partie à minima de
ma vie personnelle et familiale
j'y serais jamais allé j'aurais tout
simplement renoncé pas parce que le
sacrifice est trop dur mais simplement
parce que pour moi il n'avait pas de
sens agim moi c'est important d'avoir
cet équilibre et jean plus je pense
honnêtement que le fait d'avoir cet
équilibre aussi avec ma vie personnelle
et familiale fait deux mois la
dirigeante que je suis donc ça ça va
deux paires donc il faut absolument en
effet combattre ses croyances une femme
qui a dit un truc intéressant qui quand
on ne légifère pas on trouve des excuses
et quand on légifère on trouve des
femmes seules qui a dit ça c'est
christine lagarde présidente de la bce
elle a raison ça rejoint ce qu'on disait
avant sur le fait de faire des quotas
encore une fois pour les femmes à des
postes de direction à des postes à
responsabilité et quotas c'est toujours
un sujet sensible parce que les femmes
peuvent aussi se dire que du coup elle y
arrive parce que le quota est une fois
de plus parce qu'elles ne sont pas
capables donc c'est important à nouveau
travailler sensible est maintenant les
quotas aujourd'hui je pense que c'est
une nécessité pourquoi parce que je
pense que les femmes comme on le disait
ont besoin de penser que c'est possible
et pour ça elles ont besoin d'avoir
plein de modèles de réussite différents
avec des styles différents avec les
exigences différentes avec des critères
différentes d'avoir deux trois quatre
cinq femmes qui sont des wonder woman
qui ont des hautes responsabilités qui
font si la fête de l'école week-end et
qui se lève à 5 heures pour faire du
yoga c'est magnifique c'est génial mais
ça ça ne parle pas à toutes les femmes
et donc ses quotas ça permet aussi
justement d'avoir bain des nombre
important de femmes qui incarnent cette
diversité et qui permettent à toutes ces
femmes de se projeter de se reconnaître
et qui disent bon bah là on de romane ce
n'était pas pour moi mais ce c'est là
peut-être et oui en fait quoi de femmes
managers pour le coucher chez maison du
parce que cette parité homme femme sur
les postes encore ils font à
responsabilité pasta direction et déjà
respectée avant que la loi vous y
contraignent d'ici quelques années alors
oui parce qu on est à 50 % au niveau du
comex on est à 50 % au niveau du conseil
d'administration on est à 50 % au niveau
du top sont au delà même 70% nos
promotions internes sont décernés à des
femmes donc on est en effet une
entreprise très féminisée mais on a eu
la chance d'être nommé top 5 du sbf 120
pour la féminisation des instances
dirigeantes c'est à dire que la profil
et à compétences égales vous choisirez
une femme plutôt qu'un homme sur un
poster à recruter alors pas du tout nous
ont dit qu'elles sont fausses pas comme
ça oui non vraiment pas ça peut arriver
je veux dire cette configuration qui
arrive ça peut alors nous on est
vraiment à la mixité à la diversité donc
c'est très important d'aller chercher
cet équilibre d'ailleurs on parle de
l'égalité hommes-femmes on pourrait
parler aussi de mixité sociale enfin on
s'engage aujourd'hui maison du monde
dans l'égalité des chances de façon plus
importante que par le passé avec
notamment ce combat égalité homme femme
mais aussi notamment l'égalité des
chances et l'accès pour les jeunes ont
notamment issus de milieux défavorisés à
l'emploi il ya beaucoup d'idées
préconçues sur sur la façon de diriger
d'un homme ou d'une femme comme quoi un
vrai les femmes sera un peu plus
prudente les hommes peut prendre plus de
risques c'est quoi ces clichés tout ça
ou est-ce que voilà ça dépend finalement
du tempérament de la personnalité du
dirigeant dépendamment de son sexe alors
oui la grande question du leadership
féminin ou des leaderships masculin je
pense que en effet c'est pas une
question de genre il ya plein de
l'énergie tout comme il ya des
leaderships de petites entreprises qui
sont très différentes des leaderships
des grandes entreprises quand on fonde
une start up c'est pas les mêmes
compétences dont on a besoin que quand
on doit restructurer une entreprise très
importante donc je pense qu'en effet on
peut pas prendre de raccourcis je pense
que le premier très moi que je trouve
chez les femmes c'est cette prise de
recul ce sens de la perspective parce
que justement comme je le disais tout à
l'heure le travail est un des aspects de
nos vies mais pour beaucoup d'entre nous
nous sommes maman pour ma part j'ai
trois enfants des ancizes en quatre ans
ça prend plein espace dans ma vie
avec ma famille et puis j'ai d'autres
vies par ailleurs et donc le fait
d'avoir cet équilibre d'abord un nous
donne plus naturellement ce sens du
recul et donc permet de donner des
perspectives aux choses et nous rend
aussi très concrète très dans l'action
tr dans l'efficacité passe quand on
donne et on veut que ce soit efficace
pour justement avoir du temps pour
toutes ces vies donc ça c'est le premier
truc c'est vraiment ce côté très concret
très pragmatique avec cette prise de
recul après on prête beaucoup aussi aux
femmes le management par l'empathie il
parle écoute je pense que les coudes ce
n'est pas l'apanage des femmes c'est
vrai que dans l'école historique de
leadership ont été plutôt sur un
management voilà assez autocratique avec
une vision très assertive et le fait de
poser des questions ou de demander
conseil était vu comme un signe de
manque de vision de fragilité je pense
que tout ça quand même beaucoup évolué
et les jeunes générations le monde que
ce soit les femmes que ce soit les
hommes c'est pas facile la vie de femmes
chefs d'entreprise faut trouver ou 10e
directement le bon équilibre entre la
vie de famille la vie professionnelle
entre jongler entre le bureau à la
maison ça reste plus difficile quand on
est une femme quand on est un homme
alors c'est quand même en effet la
grande question et je pense que c'est
c'est une des raisons importantes et
juste pour lesquelles en effet les
femmes se projettent pas dans les postes
à haute responsabilité
alors on va pas se mentir est-ce que
c'est beaucoup de travail oui est ce que
ça prend énormément d'énergie absolument
est ce que c'est le double de la charge
mon talent habituel et ben en fait je
pense que c'est là où je crois la
différence se fait c'est que par exemple
moi j'ai plein de choses dans ma tête
tout le temps mais je n'appelle pas ça
une charge et pour moi c'est très
important la perception et
l'interprétation que l'on fait des
choses fait toute la différence je crois
que véritablement ça doit rester un
choix positif doit pas être vécue comme
une contrainte si on se met à parler de
charge mentale alors du coup on est en
train de subir et du coup ça devient
pénible moi j'ai l'habitude de jongler
et plein de choses et plein de choses
dans ma tête c'est le choix que je fais
c'est mon rythme et ça me va bien et
tant que c'est un choix positif du coup
je le vis très bien je pense que ça
parle déjà de la question j'ai lu j'ai
vu ce chiffre là du baromètre women
equity partners comme quoi les
entreprises dirigées par des femmes
afficherait une meilleure rentabilité
32% de plus
une réaction
alors pour moi je pense qu'il ya quand
même en effet alors c'est difficile de
trouver des raisons comme ça mais je
pense que ce côté un peu je suis à
l'écouté je suis en concertation permet
aux femmes d'avoir une compréhension
assez intime de l'organisation moi je
passe ma vie à poser des questions à mes
collaborateurs je crois que ça me permet
de bien comprendre l'organisation et
donc pour arriver à sortir le meilleur
l'organisation est optimisé notamment
les modes opératoires on sait que pleins
d'idées viennent du terrain moi j'adore
passer du temps en magasin donner la
voix aux collaborateurs c'est déjà le
début la solution on parlait des freins
qui pénalise les femmes jeudi l'album
est ce que vous avez dit ou pas
d'ailleurs victime de misogynie de
machisme et voilà est-ce que c'est
quelque chose que j'ai vécue dans votre
carrière jusqu'aux sommets - après
j'imagine au sommet évidemment non j'ai
eu la chance de pas ne pas me sentir
victime de ce long de choses peut-être
la seule chose que je peux dire il
pourrait s'assimiler à cela c'est une
fois que j'étais dirigeante
c'est le côté on a peur pour moi on a
peur qu'en fait ce soit difficile on a
peur que combiné est en fait une sorte
d'instinct de protection qui n'est pas
nécessaire parce que nous aussi c'est un
choix positivement en fait on se
débrouille et on le veut et on souhaite
et on sait brute pour que ça marche donc
voilà pas la misogynie j'ai toujours
senti des bons sentiments la
bienveillance à mon égard et parfois
plus que nécessaire bon là merci pour ce
témoignage julie walbaum dont peut-être
général de maison du monde merci merci
beaucoup et s'il ya bien domaines dans
lesquels les femmes ont du mal à se
frayer un chemin c'est celui-là tech
enfin pas tout vous allez pas
et oui sandra ray est à la tête une
start up prometteuses bonjour emilie
alors être une femme dans la tech de la
pas handicaper j'envisage de nos
confrères et oui ça lui a même permis de
sortir du lot et d'ailleurs ça lui a
plutôt réussi puisqu'elle fait partie du
classement forbes et 20 entrepreneurs
préféré des français aux côtés d'un
certain alain afflelou ou d'un françois
henri pinault elle a également été
désignée ambassadrice de la french touch
lors de la cop 21 et puis elle a été
récompensée par le prestigieux et mighty
technology review ça c'est donc pour le
seuil de fourni on parle maintenant de
sa start up en quoi ce qu'elle est pour
le coup prometteuse alors glowy c'est
son nom ambitionne de révolutionner la
lumière dans nos villes comment et bien
grâce à une bactérie bioluminescente
destiné à remplacer l'éclairage nocturne
des bâtiments des panneaux de
signalisation et de certains lampadaires
incroyable une bactérie bon on va y
revenir bien sûr mais d'abord
parlez-nous des effets néfastes j'ai
envie de dire de l'éclairage urbain
pourquoi ce qu'est l'urgence alors il
faut savoir c'est éclairage à un coût en
france il s'élève à 2 milliards d'euros
par an il représente 37 % de la facture
électrique des collectivités et puis au
niveau de la planète il utilise 15% de
l'électricité mondiale est il
responsable de 5 % des gaz à effet de
serre on n'oublie pas non plus les
effets sur la biodiversité avec par
exemple des dégâts sur la migration des
oiseaux ou encore la reproduction des
insectes et glory donc réseau ce
problème de pollution lumineuse serré si
vous avez une lumière très douce très
apaisante dans les tons bleu vert que
l'on peut regarder longuement sans
s'abîmer les yeux une lumière j'ai envie
de dire presque hypnotique poétique qui
fait appel à notre imaginaire et nous
renvoie et bien à l'univers des lits
fioles et des êtres aquatique est donc
cette lumière emilie les issues d'une
bactérie
bioluminescente sequana bioluminescence
j'ai appris un mois aujourd'hui alors
c'est une réaction chimique certains
gènes vont produire des molécules et
sous l'effet d'un apport d'oxygène elles
vont produire elle-même des photons donc
de la lumière et j'ai envie de vous dire
que glowy n'a rien inventé parce que ça
fait presque 4 milliards d'années que la
nature produit sa propre lumière vous a
peut-être déjà vu david ces images de
béquilles sully mine à san diego ou à
porto rico ce sont tous ces petits êtres
aquatique plancton poisson ou encore
calamar qui s'allument la nuit tombée
pour dissuader un prédateur ou à tirer
il faut savoir que 80 % des organismes
marins fonds doté de ce pouvoir le même
d'ailleurs que sa vie des lucioles et
donc cendrars est on revient elle a
décidé de travailler sur cette bactérie
qu'elle a récupérés dans la mer
exactement la recette bactéries les
normes et cultiver en laboratoire puis
placée dans un aquarium pour la faire
vivre il suffit de lui fournir tous les
nutriments dont elle a besoin c'est très
facile c'est comme si vous nourrissez
votre poisson rouge finalement vous
verser une petite poudre dans l'aquarium
et le tour est joué la bactérie va
pouvoir se reproduire à l'infini et
produire sa bioluminescence en continu
et ce qui est génial c'est que cette
cette lumière n'a pas de fin de vie un
peu enfin contrairement plutôt aux piles
aux ampoules et en plus elle est
biodégradable et bio sourcés
contrairement aux led qui certes sont
moins énergivore que les impôts les
ampoules incandescentes mais qui sont
fabriqués vous savez avec des métaux
rares qui sont produits extraits de
manière assez polluantes quand même à
l'autre bout du monde et qui de toute
façon ne sont pas recyclés la lumière
bioluminescente elle est 100% en
organique et dégagent 99 % de co2 en
moins que les led les médications
pratique quand pourra-t-on utiliser ces
bactéries puis pour quel usage alors
pour l'instant la start up se concentre
uniquement sur l'éclairage urbain
d'ailleurs elle a prévu de tester
prochainement son premier panneau bio
luminescents à rambouillet et ce sera
l'occasion de tester un paramètre
essentiel la température car il faut
savoir que pour se développer la
bactérie a besoin d'une température
comprise entre 10 et 40 degrés à vous
aime bien mais qu'est ce qui se passe
dans le thermomètre descend en dessous
c'est souvent pas de problème nous dit
sandra ray car l'eau de l'aquarium est
capable de s'autoréguler mais c'est
quand même un point 1 point à vérifier
sur le terrain et non pas seulement en
laboratoire alors et me dit vous nous
parlez d'éclairage urbain ce qui est
très bien on pourrait pourquoi produire
sa propre lumière comme ça chez soi à la
maison en s'occupant sa bactérie un
petit peu comme d'un comme des poissons
savent à face est le vôtre chloé alors
pour l'instant glory se concentre
uniquement je voulais dit sur sur
l'éclairage urbain d'ailleurs il faudra
que c'est une lumière qui éclaire certes
plus qu une veilleuse mais qui n'est pas
fonctionnel au point de servir de lampe
de bureau ou de lampes de cuisine on va
dire que c'est plus une lumière
d'ambiance qui d'ailleurs est utilisé
également dans des espaces dédiés des
sortes de caucourt on les appelle les
glos zen room qui vous met apparemment
dans un état proche de la méditation et
de l'hypnose en 17 minutes donc pourquoi
pas un jour équipes et les spas et les
hôpitaux pour apaiser les malades gloïn
extraits ne l'exclus pas mais pour
l'instant elle préfère se concentrer
donc sur l'éclairage public avec plus
d'une cinquantaine de projets
d'aménagement d'ici 2023 donc l'année
prochaine à 2003 qui commence
aujourd'hui merci mignon voilà c'est la
fin de pourvu que ça dure les missions
qui rend les co-responsables sur public
sénat émission à voir ou revoir sur
public sénat et en replay sur
publicsenat.fr rendez vous dans deux
semaines
[Musique]
c'était pourvu que ça dure avec le
soutien décoder ds
revoir ce programme en replay sur
publicsenat.fr
[Musique]